jean marc bonjour alors tout d'abord que
peut dire le gouvernement pour justifier
le maintien de ces mesures d'urgence ou
bien vous savez il va faire il va la
justifier évidemment par la papa la
situation sanitaire que l'on constate
les chiffres l'administration était
obligé de maintenir la pression
on est un peu dans le troisième acte de
cette crise le premier acte vous
souvenez en mars
eh bien on avait fait voter un état
d'urgence sanitaire qui instaurait un
confinement total pour toute la
population à l'exception de celles qui
travaillent mais évidemment dans le
secteur de la santé et le commerce
alimentaire savez quand même été un choc
terrible mais ça a été vécu par beaucoup
comme une atteinte grave à la liberté
individuelle
elle a été acceptée par par l'ensemble
de la population tant bien que mal mais
elle a été acceptée deuxième hat et bien
le gouvernement avait décidé la fin du
confinement ceux et ils avaient organisé
progressivement la sortie de confinement
organisée en urgence en maintenant des
contrôles et des restrictions cette loi
devait nous encadrer jusqu'au 31 octobre
on s'aperçoit maintenant qu'elle ne
suffira pas donc troisième ac on va la
jouer maintenant jusque en mars de
l'année prochaine avec des mesures de
restriction partielle en se réservant un
droit éventuelle de durcir la situation
dans certains cas c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui se passe à marseille à bordeaux ou
sans doute à les restrictions de
réunions publiques privées alors subtil
dit c'est qu'il avance finalement les
les conditions sanitaires
mais le débat politique à l'assemblée
l'a quand même être très très chaud
parce que les mesures de restriction et
bien ont une dimension évidemment
liberticide c'est une atteinte à la
liberté individuelle
on l'a déjà beaucoup dit même s'il
s'agit de sauver des vies humaines
on n'a pas cette culture d'autant que
les chiffres de la pandémie sont
menaçants certes mais ils ne sont pas
catastrophiques dont le souci du
gouvernement est bien c'est de bloquer
la circulation du virus mais c'est aussi
de ne pas asphyxier l'économie parce que
dans ce cas là ce serait catastrophique
les mesures de restrictions vont
désormais peser sur les libertés un
d'ordre privé social de circulation de
réunion mais on va tout faire pour que
les restrictions
au tec pas ne gêne pas la vie des
entreprises d'autant que nous sommes
actuellement en voie de reprise de
l'activité donc c'est certainement pas
le moment de casser cette reprise
ça va être difficile un seul exemple les
écoles si on ferme les écoles
eh bien on va empêcher un des deux
parents d'aller au travail et on ne peut
pas se le permettre
est ce que ces mesures de restriction
partage le jeu politique jean marc alors
c'est ça qui est très très compliqué à
gérer parce que le plan d'urgence fait
débat mais ne permet pas de trouver une
majorité homogène pour pour soutenir ce
ce plan qui une majorité qui sera
courroux contre d'ailleurs en gros la
classe politique suit l'opinion publique
l'opinion est plutôt favorable à des
mesures de restriction mais sans doute
plus pour les autres que pour soi même
l'opinion a peur du virus donc à droite
comme à gauche on a des pour et on a des
comptes y compris d'ailleurs chez des
écologistes qui sont pourtant assez
sceptique il croit aux médecines
naturelles par au vaccin mais là en ce
moment il s'interroge parce que ça
risque de les toucher sa touche leur
voisinage ça touche les enfants ça
touche les vieilles personnes ce qui est
nouveau c'est que l'état a donné la main
aux pouvoirs locaux au maire et au
préfet et là on voit des mères qui
critiquaient le pouvoir central en
disant que finalement il était trop dur
et bien c'est mr ans vient aujourd'hui à
des positions qui sont encore plus
sévères le maire de marcel le maire de
bordeaux qui s'occupait des sapins de
noël est obligé de protéger sa
population
a bordeaux c'est flagrant le maire
tendance verte veut sauver son école
d'économie de sa région il veut sauver
l'image de sa région dont il prône des
mesures qu'il n'avait sans doute jamais
envisagé de prendre auparavant alors ça
c'est très intéressant parce qu'on va
avoir une partie de l'opinion qui va se
plaindre qu'elle est que l'état ne
prenait pas ses responsables ne prend
pas ses responsabilités
mais ce sont les mêmes qui disaient il
ya deux mois que l'état en faisait trop
alors l'écart grosso modo fait le job
mais il le fait en général trop tard 1
avec les masses ils étaient en retard
avec les tests il est en tout cas avec
les régions et bien il est un peu en or
ce décalage ne crée pas un climat de
sécurité
or ce dont nous avons besoin notamment
pour restaurer la confiance notamment
pour assurer la reprise de l'économie
c'est d'être rassuré merci beaucoup
jean marc sylvestre pour toutes ces
précisions